what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the room around up our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week and at the
end of the episode we do want to follow
up on the marvel lawsuit going on right
now in case you guys don't know what
we're talking about we made a video on
it yesterday but particularly we reached
out to you guys to figure out what your
thoughts are on this whole thing and
honestly the results were somewhat
surprising but before we get into that
we've got some leaks and some stuff from
the flash movie that's coming out next
year now one of the big issues and we
actually really haven't talked about any
of the dc films here on geek culture
explained
at all i think one of the biggest issues
is that it's just a giant disorganized
mess
[Laughter]
the dc film landscape is about as far
from organized as anything can be it's
the film equivalent of like a 15 year
old's bedroom right just stuff
everywhere but there was an image that
was released recently that actually gave
us the batman logo on what looks like a
red suit with the flash logo spray
painted over top of it now rumors abound
in terms of what this actually means as
far as the bigger film goes some people
are speculating that something's going
to happen to either michael keaton's
bruce wayne
or to ben affleck's bruce wayne and that
in turn ezra miller is going to have to
take up the role of being both batman
and flash at the same time honestly i
think this has to do more with the
villain and the reason why is because we
don't know anything about the villain
yet right no real information has been
released because the movie is based on
the flashpoint paradox story from dc
we're largely left to believe that it's
reverse flash even then reverse flash
wasn't necessarily the main enemy of the
story per se the story didn't really
have a main enemy it was basically a
story where like things popped off and
stuff was going bad because barry allen
saved his mom's life so he had to go
back in time and basically let her die
the closest thing you get to a villain
in that story is probably like the
atlanteans waging war against the
amazons right but it's not really a true
villain but the cool thing about this is
that if we had to pick a villain while
some people are saying that this suit
may belong to eobard thon it's entirely
possible but eobard thon's color scheme
is yellow so the suit colors don't
really match if i'm a betting man and
this is just me being a comic book fan
i've got no evidence to support this
claim whatsoever i would want it to be
red death those of you guys who don't
know who red death is he was awesome so
dc had this story that was called dark
nights metal and it was basically this
story that really went all the way back
to the death of batman at the hands of
darkseid during final crisis but one of
the important things here is you
basically had what was called a dark
multiverse it was basically a multiverse
where all the worst things that can
happen do happen and we were only given
a very very small portion of what this
multiverse looked like with regards to
dark knight's metal dc hasn't really
explored the dark multiverse in its full
capacity which i'm kind of surprised
about because it was just this amazing
concept but in one of these universes in
the dark multiverse there came a point
when batman had actually strapped the
flash to the front of the batmobile and
then drove it into the speed force and
then in effect merged with the flash and
came out as a character called red death
he was a villain but it was basically an
evil version of batman with the powers
of the flash now the logos are
completely different they don't look
anything alike but the color of the
super red death was red the biggest
issue that you have with that theory is
that's a lot to throw into a single
movie even if we remove the whole
element of like the dark multiverse and
just say something happened and
something popped off and who knows
whatever the answer is and we basically
have this version of the batman with the
flash's powers that's still a lot to
kind of cram in there having said that
it's not outside the realm of
possibility when it comes to dc films
they're notorious for making poor
decisions the only exception to that is
the joker right that movie was amazing
and christopher nolan's dark knight
trilogy even though i don't really
consider that to be incontinuity with
the rest of the dc eu it should be
because it was amazing but the important
thing here
is that's entirely something they could
throw in there having said that we're
still just kind of left in the dark in
all honesty i'm kind of disappointed
with the way that warner brothers is
handling the marketing for all their
movies there's never been a better time
to market the hell out of these movies
and to just drum up a ton of interest
but there never really seems to be a
whole lot coming out about them it's
like aquaman suit looks different we get
this logo with like the flash symbols
spray painted over the batman logo you
know those are like the only two pieces
of news that you get in like a six month
period right like it's a little
disappointing but regardless i want to
know what you guys think who do you guys
think the main villain is for this new
flash movie coming out at the end of
next year i'm curious what your answers
are going to be but moving on to our
next topic chris pratt has been pegged
to play mario or really voice mario in
the new mario animated film now i don't
know why we need a new animated film we
got a super mario brothers movie in 1993
with bob hoskins and john leguizamo and
that one chick who played princess peach
which really felt more like april o'neil
from the teenage mutant ninja turtles
franchise all right in all seriousness i
kind of enjoyed the original mario
brothers movie it's like my guilty
pleasure film don't judge me
don't judge me
dennis hopper was a terrible bowser but
while chris pratt has been pegged to
play the role of mario and a lot of
people are very very happy about a super
mario animated film a lot of people are
very unhappy about chris pratt playing
the role of mario now this comes from
three different positions so the first
complaint that people have is that a
person of italian descent should have
been the one the voice over mario
because mario's an italian plumber
another group of people are complaining
because they feel like there are too
many super high profile actors given
roles that could go to lesser
lesser-known actors to help boost their
profile but i would say a lion's share
of the anger about chris pratt playing
mario comes from chris pratt's personal
politics and this has really split a lot
of people in terms of where they stand
there are people who are coming from
this from the perspective of saying he
attends a church that is staunchly
anti-lgbtq
he's made statements that indicate and
show that he is not in favor or
supportive of the trans community i.e
people calling him transphobic then
there are people on the other side of
the equation saying it doesn't matter as
long as his personal politics do not
play into the actual statements made by
mario over the course of the film
basically mario never comes out and says
i am against the trans community that
his personal politics don't matter
they're saying that people on the other
side who are complaining about this are
doing what social media always does
looking for a reason to complain about
things that has really kind of split
things up so i'm gonna play the role of
philip defranco and i'm gonna dodge this
bullet and i'm gonna ask you guys the
question what do you think is going on
here how do you guys stand on this are
you in favor of chris pratt playing
mario are you against chris pratt
playing mario i'm very curious about
this having said that the most exciting
information coming out for the nintendo
switch was recently revealed and when i
say the most exciting i mean like the
most exciting information essentially
since launch so what we found out here
is that at the end of this year in
october so like next month nintendo is
basically releasing a bunch of n64 and
sega genesis games for the nintendo
switch one of the other things you're
doing is that for those of you guys who
came from the n64 if you're like me and
you grew up in the era of the n64
playstation arrow though technically i
was really more of a super nintendo kid
you guys are so familiar with those
controllers you're also familiar with
the second genesis controller and so
what they're doing is they're releasing
n64 and sega genesis controllers that
work with a nintendo switch now some of
the titles for this these are not all
the titles they're releasing but here's
some of the titles they're releasing
it's cool man
super mario 64. the legend of zelda
ocarina of time mario kart 64. star fox
64 dr mario 64 and mario tennis 64. now
to be honest with you guys i'm not
overly surprised that a majority of the
games they're releasing from the n64 are
mario games it is nintendo after all you
would want to make sure that if you're
going to port in games that are
basically from previous consoles that
you would bring in the ips that you've
made right the most popular ips if i'm
being honest with you guys those games
are cool i really can't wait until they
get super mario sunshine is super mario
sunshine on the switch i haven't fired
mine up in forever it's on the switch
i'm gonna go download it right now and
play it like right now like as soon as
i'm done with this and just spend the
rest of the day playing super mario
sunshine that game was amazing i love
super mario sunshine god i love that
having said that i am hyped for ocarina
of time now personally i'm more of a
majora's mask fan now majora's mask is
coming out later on uh it'll be like the
second wave as they're calling it of n64
titles being released so those of you
guys who are zelda fans yes right you're
gonna get the trinity man we already got
breath of the wild then you get ocarina
of time and then you get majora's mask
right but again i was more of a majora's
mask fan having said that i can
appreciate ocarina of time it's probably
one of the most landmark zelda games
ever created absolutely loved it after
all the other games they look cool right
this mario kart never never was a big
fan of mario kart 64. but here are the
list of games they're releasing from the
sega genesis sonic the hedgehog 2
streets of rage 2 echo the dolphin
castlevania bloodlines contra hardcore
shinobi 3 and strider now there are a
few other games we're releasing as well
f0x they're going to release pokemon
snap at a future point in time but let
me tell you guys something man
streets of rage man dude i love streets
of rage back in the day that game was
legit and the soundtrack was amazing
[Music]
dude i love that soundtrack man that
soundtrack for streets of rage was fire
and the game itself was an absolute
blast if i'm being honest with you guys
man
it's literally a game-gasm if there even
is a word for that right a lot of these
games i grew up on man sonic 2 oh my god
i never really played tonight well i
take that back i played sonic 1 but it
was one of those things where like you
played at the store right like you guys
know what i'm talking about but
nonetheless like sonic 2 was the first
like game that i bought that i took home
and played that my parents bought for me
i loved sonic 2. i liked sonic 3 it was
cool you could fly but sonic 2 was
better right that game was absolutely
fantastic i grew up on these man so it's
so cool to see my childhood brought into
the modern era right my ability to just
kind of go back and and just relive life
when i was like seven eight nine years
old it's so cool here's the question
that we really gotta ask here right
here's here's a million dollar question
are they ever gonna bring back the super
scope six i doubt it man that thing had
the best potential that they totally
screwed up the super scope six was
awesome i had it i had the super scope
six back in the day it sucked like the
wise i'll say the games for it sucked
the super scope six was a great concept
but i'm excited to see all these things
from my childhood returning right so i'm
i'm i am super hyped about this now on
that same note kind of continuing our
discussion here about gaming early talks
about a marvel vs capcom 2 remaster are
coming and i think we can all pretty
much just admit here we're in the age of
remastered games which is not
necessarily a bad thing i think it's
kind of a good thing i mean if i'm being
honest with you guys this is one of the
things we've talked about before one of
the things that i hate about the modern
day gaming community is the games as a
service model that combined with the
standard practice of aaa developers
releasing unfinished games and then
charging you over the course of
expansions for the finished game right
so they are in effect charging you like
a hundred and twenty dollars for a video
game they're just not necessarily
marketing it that way right but that's
basically what's going on like cd
projekt red and cyberpunk is a perfect
example destiny is a perfect example of
that right incomplete games that are
released over time in completed packages
that are basically considered to be
expansions right i do miss the age when
we got like full games right gta right
they're probably not going to give us a
gta 6 for a long time but grand theft
auto complete and total games uncharted
complete and total games right marvel vs
capcom these kind of fighting games that
have colossal audiences right just
massive player bases that are hugely
popular we're all just kind of in the
age of remastered games so i don't
really mind the fact that games are
being remastered having said that i was
never really a marvel vs capcom guy i
know a lot of you guys are like what boo
hiss boo hiss credibility destroyed
unsubbed
you suck rob
i know a lot of you guys are probably
just just
boo hissing the hell out of me but
honestly i could never get into the
marvel vs capcom series it just wasn't
really my thing right that kind of
fighting game hadn't been my thing for a
long long time right i wouldn't say i
grew out of it i would say that i just
kind of lost interest in it right my
interest sort of you know changed into
other things but having said that i do
recognize marvel vs capcom does have a
huge audience right now it's one of the
most popular video game franchises in
the world so let me know what you guys
think down in the comments are you
excited for the remaster are you kind of
like i'd rather just have a new marvel
vs capcom game with new characters and
things like that let me know what you
guys think now continuing on the trailer
for stranger things season four came out
recently it's a minute and a half long
we'll have a link to it down in the
description not a whole lot to go on
there there are a couple things that did
catch my attention one dustin looks a
lot more confident than he used to which
is cool lucas's box cut looks awesome he
looks like kid from kid and play back in
the 90s those guys who don't know who
kid and play is i don't know what to
tell you you guys missed out in the
worst way you need to go watch house
party that movie is the tits but
nonetheless he looks like kid right just
obviously not as pale but the other
thing that i noticed here and what i'm
kind of hoping they're not shooting for
is the kind of like the conjuring vibe
right you guys what i'm talking about
because the movie or at least the show
looks like it kind of opens up like back
in the 50s and then you jump forward to
like the 80s and i'm hoping that we
don't really get this like you know well
at one point the house was haunted and
then here come you know the cast of
stranger things to clean the house you
know i'm hoping that doesn't happen and
it probably won't in truth when we're
talking about stranger things it has its
own feel it has its own kind of vibe
right that sort of throwback that retro
wave synth wave kind of feel which is
really one of the things that i think
made it so popular is that it felt so
different from a lot of the shows that
were being released at that point in
time plus it was told from the
perspective of kids and it was always
fun to see the world through the eyes as
young kids who are being you know
basically swept away into the upside
down and have to fight their way out
it was a cool concept right i am excited
to see what they do by no means am i
knocking on this i just really hope they
don't go in the direction of like the
conjuring or something along those lines
because as cool as the conjuring is
that's its own franchise and honestly
it's kind of been done to death so that
needs to stay where it is and hopefully
stranger things does its own thing
having said that the next little bit
that we have here is actually something
that a lot of people seem kind of pissed
about right so one division as you guys
know was kind of being marketed to the
general public as a show that was
essentially nominated for an emmy and
then it won none of them right it didn't
get anything at the emmy awards right
nothing got absolutely nothing at the
emmys and it pissed off a lot of people
because a lot of people felt like it was
a beating switch right it was kind of
like hey you know come to the emmys you
know wanda vision that kind of stuff and
the whole idea of any real potential of
one division being entertained in any
capacity at the emmys was done strictly
to get people who are fans of the mcu to
watch the image right because they
realize how many people are interested
in that and that in truth i have to
believe typical reward shows like the
emmys or even the academy awards things
like that are kind of losing popularity
because a lot of people are moving in
the direction of wanting to see more
diversity at those awards ceremonies and
they're just kind of not getting it so
there's somebody just not watching it
and so because of that it seems like a
lot of people were basically they really
felt duped into watching the emmys under
the belief that one division would win
something or or get any kind of
acknowledgement whatsoever which didn't
really seem to be the case not the most
important thing there uh in all reality
i think they have a legitimate beef i
think there's a legit reason to be upset
there but at the end of the day it's
just kind of the name of the game i
think that that with the emmys doing
that i think what it does is actually
worsen the interest people have in the
emmys because anybody who would have
tuned in and said hey one division might
win something and then they ultimately
kind of get screwed or just like alright
whatever well then i'm not gonna worry
about watching the emmys again and they
call it a day this i think combined with
a lot of high-profile directors martin
scorsese dylan villeneuve coming out and
saying like mcu movies aren't real
movies right they're they're like the
walmart equivalent of hollywood i think
it's putting a lot of bad taste in a lot
of people's mouths and what they're
seeing is old hollywood versus new
hollywood and that shows like the emmys
or the academy awards or award shows
like the tonys and things like that are
part of old hollywood and they're moving
away from that they're walking away from
that right so again i think this is
doing nothing more than just increasing
the rift that exists between a lot of
younger viewers and a lot of older
viewers when it comes to these kinds of
things so uh emmys tony's academy awards
right
get it together man because you're
losing folks
having said that our last little bit of
discussion here again kind of ties back
into the video that we did about the
lawsuit between uh the estates of these
various writers and artists who had
created a lot of these landmark
characters in marvel comics spider-man
thor doctor strange and so on and so
forth and the lawsuit they have against
marvel involving the copyrights of these
various creations now we reached out to
you guys in a poll and said who do you
agree with here are you on the side of
marvel or are you on the side of the
families and by a pretty good majority
you guys chose that you were on the side
of marvel in this and a lot of the the
arguments that were presented there
right a lot of the comments that were
made were people basically saying look i
mean these guys deserve recognition for
the characters they created which they
get right like spider-man created by
stan lee and steve ditko that kind of a
thing that's actually been standard
practice since the jerry siegel and joe
schuster lawsuits back in the day as
well as the kirby lawsuits that came
later on but they are getting the kind
of recognition they deserve a lot of the
arguments that you guys are making is no
right like stan lee steve get co these
guys they created that as work for hire
they were paid by marvel to create
characters for marvel right they were
paid money it'd be different if marvel
had just like stolen their concept right
if it wasn't actually spider-man but
something similar to spider-man and that
marvel stole it called it spider-man and
then sold it right just started
marketing it as their own comic book
then a lot of you guys said that would
make perfect sense but these families or
these individuals these creators were
paid by marvel to create these
characters which in turn were owed by
marvel based on the contracts or the
payment they accepted and the little
legends on the back that marvel said
you're accepting this payment under the
idea that the character in the work that
you're doing is owned by marvel and so
in the end these families have no real
argument here right so you know it's i'm
curious to see how this whole thing is
going to play out i'm curious to see
what side this is going to take if i
understand it correctly the uh the the
families of the estates are actually
filing to have a jury trial which would
basically allow this to go before a jury
as you would expect and for average
individuals to be the ones to make the
call as opposed to having it strictly go
before a judge which is what disney
wants now i imagine the reason why
that's happening is because if the
estates have it their way and it goes
before a jury they can tug on those
heartstrings right whereas if they're
sitting in front of a judge it's
strictly the rule of law and the
heartstrings of the people who are
watching have no play in this whatsoever
now whether or not that's actually the
case i have no real idea right just kind
of my thought here but again you know
it's cool i think we might start doing
that when it comes to stuff like this
reaching out to you guys seeing what you
think we already do polls on a regular
basis but kind of incorporating that
stuff into the videos that we make
because at the end of the day i feel
like it makes you guys feel like you
belong right like you guys are part of
this geek culture explained family
speaking of which we need to name you
guys what are we going to name you i
thought about calling you guys like rob
core i don't know what do you guys think
we should name you i have no real idea
give us name ideas down in the comments
give us give us ideas suggestions the
whole nine yards maybe we'll hold some
kind of a competition and the winner
gets something right they get to like
appear on an episode uh and maybe like
host an episode of the rumor roundup or
something like that i have no idea how
we'll do it with that being said guys
though we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace
you